don't you just love flying it's the most
amazing experience who would have
thought that would even be possible such
a wonderful experience that how could it
possibly go wrong
we've just recovered from the Pepsi
memes now for you guys who don't know
I'm sure a lot of you know already
there's been this video of a man being
dragged off the airplane let's let's
have a little watch in case you haven't
seen it I love this guy by the way he is
so [ __ ] happy that he got to keep his
seat you know that he's like I got to
keep my seat [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] man yes
literally dragging him out of his seat
and I know what you thinking what did he
do
did he offend the crew maybe the
passengers maybe he said something
really mean what's happening here is
absolutely horrible I can't believe it's
happening it's just so bizarre okay let
me give a little bit of better context
here so basically what happens in a lot
of airlines in America especially as I
understand is that they over booked the
flights because a ton of people that
booked the flight don't actually show up
so a way for companies airlines to make
even more money on seats for people that
don't show up is to sell more tickets
then it exists on the airplane everyone
shows up at the flight it does happen
and that way clearly they can't fly the
plane you know with people sitting on
the floor so they have to accommodate
these passengers by dragging them the
[ __ ] out of the airplane not for it's
nothing funny but I'm not laughing at
him I'm laughing at how bizarre the
situation is don't get me wrong what's
happening in here is horrible but that
wasn't what happened the reason why they
dragged this guy off the plane was
because United wanted to move some of
their crew some of their employees to
another city so they didn't over booked
it they just wanted to move their people
so they're like well we're gonna throw
away the people that paid for their cut
their tickets you're up so what happened
was they said does anyone want to make a
$400 wall that will fly you in tomorrow
at 2:00 p.m. no one absolutely no one
takes that offer because who the [ __ ]
wants to stay a night in another city
until 2:00 p.m. so then they selected
some people at random and they don't
select the first-class by the way they
select whoever paid the lowest first
four people were selected and this man
did refused to leave his spot for the
United crew man
and this is what happened is that was so
confused about it first I'm like how can
you throw away someone on the plane if
he's already entered like why was he
allowed to enter if he's not allowed to
enter I'm so good
apparently they [ __ ] let him back in
again they dragged him out where did all
that blood come from that wasn't there
before what did they do to him first of
all the flight was from Chicago to
Louisville I looked that up on Google
Maps it's a very short flight it's like
an hour long it costs 174 pounds but
they offered four hundred pounds for
four people to exit why didn't they just
book him on a flight if you need your
people to go so badly it'll be cheaper
this whole thing could have been avoided
as horrible as this event is the memes
as always are delicious you know we were
blessed with Pepsi but United thank you
when we say we say you fly you fly if
not
give us a problem and we'll drag your
ass off the plane
we'll beat you so badly you'll be using
your own face as a flotation device
United Airlines I love it so much it's
always great just paying for expensive
plane tickets to then just get dragged
the [ __ ]
I guess I guess they got their employee
training video from the Dark Knight the
thing that bothers me the most about the
situation it's something I'm thinking
constantly about is if only if only that
man had a Pepsi this whole thing could
have been resolved instantly there would
not have been a problem if he just said
excuse me sir I would really like to
keep my seat they say no he's like well
can I interest you in this Pepsi oh my
god
so the memes on Twitter are absolutely
amazing here we see the exchange that
went down with Kylie Jenner amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
United if we cannot beat our competitors
we beat our customers board as a doctor
leave as a peace will seat you then
we'll beat you this is some great PR
this is some excellent peer I do have a
feeling that United it's not gonna face
this problem any longer you know I have
a feeling there's not gonna be too many
over bookings any longer
luckily oh I love this one though our
prices are unbeatable we can't say the
same for our passengers Pepsi we made
the biggest PR blunder of any major
company this year United hold my beer I
got this now the thing is the CEO of
United made a statement it reads like
this I've just seen the video from
flight 341 1 and like you all I am
shocked
I have immediately cleared my calendar
of any other commitments and I'm going
to our company's facilities at O'Hare to
conduct a personal inquiry no oh sorry
that wasn't it he made a completely
different statement basically the
equivalent of a youtuber apology trust
me I know basically saying well I'm
sorry it's your fault the CEO of United
god bless you
amazing he basically said I am quoting
directly I apologize for having to react
AMA date these customers there was also
a leaked email coming from the CEO of
United basically showing the no sign of
remorse or empathy for the situation our
employees followed established
procedures that we studied from the dark
night from the from the dark night movie
United CEO got his start at Pepsi he
came from Pepsi our Lord and Savior
United treating our customers in each
other with the respect and dignity is at
the core of who we are why don't you ask
skeins and what he thinks about that
statement airlines are all [ __ ] okay
some of them are just more [ __ ] than
others clearly United is now part of
that list
I think everyone who's flown somewhat
frequently has had a bad experience
flying I've had a similar experience
like this no no I didn't get beaten ok
don't get me the wrong way but I had a
connecting flight once the flight was
delayed but I I made it to the terminal
in time before they even started
boarding the plane but they refused to
let me on the flight because they
thought since the plane was late that I
wouldn't make it so they had without
telling me or without doing anything
they just booked me on another flight
and so seeing everyone just get on the
plane well I'm just like why aren't you
letting me on the plane this is one of
the most frustrating things I ever had
to deal with it was some when I was
gonna visit Marzia when the first times
we dated and I was just so annoyed that
I wouldn't make it to her in time it's
such a horrible thing I understand this
guy refusing to leave he paid for the
ticket he bought the ticket
you can't sell someone something that
you don't have that's fraud if you ask
me what United did is fraud I hope this
guy gets reimbursed for what happened
and no I'm not talking $400 in in money
that most likely you have to spend at
the airport or in new plane tickets
alright that was this video let me know
if you
leave a like if you did I'll see you
tomorrow with another one stay awesome
press enough is enough
I have had it with these [ __ ]
doctors on this [ __ ] plane
everybody's strapped in about the open
some [ __ ] windows outside Chicago's
hometown airline come fly the friendly
skies
[Music]